Je suis dégouté
Je viens de tourner cette vidéo
et j'avais pas mis enregistrer
Eh bé du coup je refais
Salut à vous,
Oui je sais, j'étais trop près de la caméra
avant le dimanche je vous donnais toujours une explication, un truc qui allais vous permettre de bluffer les gens
et depuis le mois d'août on a arrêté ce rituel,
on a arrêté d'ailleurs le rituel des jours de programmation
et du coup, les explications je les fait quand je veux dans la semaine.
Il y a même eu des fois où j'en ai fait 2 dans la semaine,
Néanmoins,
quand arrive le dimanche, vous êtes nombreux à me dire:
"Elle est où notre explication du dimanche?"
Donc exceptionnellement aujourd'hui je vous refais ça
Explication.
Vous allez donc bluffer les gens
*Générique*
Si vous voyez cette vidéo c'est donc la 3ème de la série que j'ai faite juste avant d'aller en Suisse
D'ailleurs, au moment, où vous regarderez cette vidéo
dimanche à 11h je serai dans mon train *siffle* direction Paris
Et si j'ai mis ces 3 vidéos là, ça voudra dire que j'ai pas pu faire là bas
ou que j'ai pas pu me connecter là bas.
Mais que par contre j'ai pu prendre de l'avance dans l'écriture des vidéos de la semaine prochaine
Et ça c'est cool !
Alors aujourd'hui je vous propose de mentaliser, non pas une personne, mais 2, 3, 4 personnes en même temps
Dans l'exemple on va partir sur 3
vous réunissez 3 amis devant vous
Vous leur donnez un papier et un crayon et vous leur demandez de créer une liste de films
Alors, 10, 20, 30 films
25, 30 films c'est quand même un truc, d'expérience je peux vous le dire, c'est assez bluffant pour eux
Ils écrivent ça à eux 3.
Si possible, des films qu'ils ont vu tous les 3
Si c'est pas le cas c'est pas très grave
mais c'est encore plus intéressant s'ils ont vu les films tous les 3
Alors je vous le dis
d'expérience,
quand on demande comme ça à des gens de créer une liste
sur un même thème
C'est toujours compliqué, il y a une espèce de blocage, de recherche ou d'imagination. Je sais pas
Donc vous pouvez les aider, les stimuler
soit en donnant vous même des films
soit en donnant des catégories de films
par exemple: "Ah vous avez pas mis de films d'action !"
ou "ah vous avez pas mis de grande comédie française"
Vous pouvez un petit peu les driver comme ça
Une fois que c'est fait vous allez leur expliquer ce qu'ils ont à faire et va falloir être très précis
Dans un 1er temps, vous leur demandez à chacun de choisir un film mentalement parmi leur propre liste
celle qu'ils ont créé
Par contre ça doit être un film qu'ils ont vu et dont ils se souviennent
Alors ils peuvent se concerter s'ils ont pas envie de choisir le même film,
Mais, peu importe pour vous
ils peuvent choisir le même film, ça n'a pas d'importance
Et là, où c'est magique
c'est que c'est pas important que vous les ayez vus les films, vous même ou pas
Ensuite, ils se mettent tous les 3 en ligne, vous vous mettez devant eux
et ils doivent tous les 3 fermer les yeux
Alors dans le temps, c'est sûr, vous y arriverez à le faire même quand ils ont les yeux ouverts
Mais ça va être plus simple, bizarrement, de le faire les yeux fermés surtout pour commencer
donc vous leur demandez à tous les 3 de fermer les yeux
et de vraiment le faire et dêtre concentrés
vous leur expliquez
que vous allez lire la liste lentement
et quand vous allez prononcer, le nom du film auquel il pense
à ce moment là précisément
pas avant
ils devront s'imaginer en train de regarder le film
ils devront pas s'imaginer assis dans le canapé etc... en mode attente
Non ils devront vraiment s'imaginer
que le films se déroule devant eux,
donc se rappeler d'un moment du film
et de le regarder, comme si c'était vraiment devant eux, comme si, il regardait de nouveau le film
et c'est essentiel d'être bien clair sur cette démarche là
Vous allez donc commencer à lire leur liste de films,
en prenant le temps de laisser quelques bonnes secondes entre chaque films
C'est important qu'ils aient ce temps là, pour rentrer dans le processus d'imagination
et vous, tout ce que vous avez à faire, durant ces quelques grosses secondes,
c'est d'observer les yeux de chacun des participants
Ils vont avoir les yeux fixes en permanence
et au moment où ils vont rentrer en processus d'imagination
Les yeux vont commencer à bouger
Et là, comme les yeux sont fermés
on s'en fiche de la dilatation de la pupille etc... de ce genre de choses.
C'est juste le mouvement qui nous intéresse
et comme vous pouvez le constater, quand les yeux bougent
il se passe des choses, on le voit très facilement
On peut donc observer plusieurs personnes en même temps
en plus si vous êtes minutieux, vous allez pouvoir voir une contraction au niveau de la machoire
une espèce de tension sur le visage
qui est une forme de concentration
J'ai remarqué également, il y a pas d'étude là dessus et j'ai pas de statistiques là dessus
C'est juste moi mon expérience personnelle
que les gens avaient tendance à déglutir quand ils se mettaient dans le processus d'imagination
mais de base fiez vous d'abord aux yeux
Ne dites pas tout de suite à quel film ils pensent,
attendez d'avoir bien fini la liste, même si vous avez déjà les films de tout le monde
il se peut, du coup, que 2 personnes aient le même film
et à la fin vous leur demandez d'ouvrir les yeux et vous le faites en mitraillette
Toi tu penses à tel film, toi tel film et toi tel film
Et là,
C'est le succès
Alors évidemment c'est du mentalisme donc c'est pas safe à 100%
C'est possible que des fois vous ayez une petite erreur ou une petite galère
C'est pas très grave et plus vous le ferez, plus vous serez entraînés et moins vous vivrez les micros erreurs
C'est ça aussi qui est bien de le faire sur 3 ou 4 personnes
c'est que si vous en avez 3 sur 4
C'est quoi qu'il arrive une grosse réussite
c'est 75% de réussite
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
et que vous allez bluffer les gens avec ça
Oui c'est un message subliminal quand je fais les pouces *rires*
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaîne si ce n'est pas déjà fait
Le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant 366 jours
donc rendez vous demain à 17h
Tchao !